Transcriber: Yiğit Yıldırım
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Merhabalar.
Az önceki sunumda ismimi duydunuz.
Ben çellistim.
Bu bir Elektro çello.
Elektro çellistim.
Aynı zamanda bir ses tasarımcısı ve
sıkı bir müzik okur yazarıyım.
Bugün size çok uzun olmayan bir
performans sergileyeceğim.
Elektro çello bir bilgisayara bağlı ve
hem akustik hem de elektronik sesler
duyacaksınız birazdan.
Performansımın öncesinde
biraz nasıl bir müzik yaptığımdan
bahsetmeyi düşünmüştüm.
Az önce kuliste arkadaşlarımla konuşurken,
karanlığın, stresin, olumsuzlukların,
bazen anksiyetenin, bazen yalnızlığın,
kısacası kötü duyguların insanı üretmeye
ittiğinden ve aslında bunun,
bu yaşadığımız olumsuzlukların o kadar da
kötü olmayabileceğinden bahsetmiştik.
Tam da böyle bi-
Müziğe başlama hikayem vardı.
Hayatımın zor dönemeçlerinden
bir tanesinde.
İşte büyüdüğüm yeri terk etmişiz,
terk etmek zorunda kalmışız.
Yeni bir yerdeyim, küçüğüm.
Çevremde pek anlaşabileceğim kimse yok.
İçine kapanık ve sadece kitap
okuyan bir çocukken,
müziğe başlamaya karar vermem aslında o
dönemki korkunç ruh halinden çıkmamı
çok kolaylaştırdı.
Ondan sonra da tüm hayatımı
inşa etmiş oldu,
müzik kariyerim.
Tam da bu bahsettiğim duygulara denk düşen
bir Edip Cansever şiiriyle
lise yıllarımda tanışmıştım.
Şiirin ismi “Yengeç”
ve bir dizesi diyor ki:
“Bir vahşet gibi yaratılır orda umut.”
Karanlığın içinden çıkan olumlu
tomurcukları, güzel hisleri ya da
güzel sonuçları anımsatır bana o şiir.
Epey uzun, belki okursunuz bir ara.
Birazdan çalacağım parçanın adı bu.
Bir vahşet gibi yaratılır orda umut.
Umarım keyif alırsınız.